vamos a recordar lo importante que fue
el trabajo de gregor mendel que fue
publicado en 1866 y es importante darse
cuenta de que después de que su trabajo
fuera publicado en 1866 no sucedió
inmediatamente de que todo el mundo
dijera amén de lo resolvió todo al igual
que un montón de veces en la ciencia los
grandes descubrimientos los que
realmente cambian la manera de pensar de
las personas no son tomados muy en serio
al principio y de hecho en 1866 un
montón de gente o bien no tomó en serio
el trabajo de méndez o bien lo ignoraron
y fue hasta la década de 1900 que las
personas ya descubrieron su trabajo y
dijeron esperar aquí hay algo muy muy
importante y posiblemente podríamos
vincularlo con las cosas que estamos
observando en el interior de las células
pero vamos a recordar un poco de qué
trata el trabajo de méndez la mayor
parte de la historia humana nos hemos
dado cuenta de que los seres vivos de
cualquier tipo parecen transmitir sus
rasgos a su descendencia podría mirarte
y decir oh tu cabello es como el de tu
papá y tus ojos son como los de tu mamá
tal vez su nariz se parece un poco a la
de los dos y caminas de manera similar a
su tío siempre nos hemos dado cuenta de
que transmitimos rasgos a nuestros hijos
pero en realidad no teníamos una forma
rigurosa de pensar en ello y
definitivamente no teníamos una manera
de hacer predicciones que fueran
comprobables basándonos en esos rasgos y
eso es lo que nos dio méndez él dijo yo
estoy observando y él hizo esto con
plantas de chícharos observé estos
factores hereditarios y puede haber
factores hereditarios sobre la altura si
estamos hablando de la planta sería la
altura de la planta
puede haber factores hereditarios en
digamos el color de la flor
el color de la flor
y reconoció que había diferentes
versiones de estos factores y así una
planta determinada podría tener una de
las versiones altas por lo tanto puede
ser que tengan una versión alta para el
factor de la altura y puede ser que
tengan una versión baja o puede ser que
tengan dos versiones altas o pueden
tener dos versiones bajas o puede ser
que tengan un factor de color rojo
y que tengan un factor de color rosa
o podrían tener dos rojos que se vería
así o dos rosas pero lo importante fue
que existían estas versiones de los
factores
hoy en día llamamos a estos factores
genes decimos que hay un gen para la
altura si hay uno o que existe un gen
para el color de la flor y a estas
variaciones de los genes en la
actualidad los llamamos alelos
por lo tanto diríamos que alguien tiene
una copia del alelo alto
y una copia del alelo bajo
todos estos son alelos
por lo tanto tienes un alelo alto y un
alelo bajo
y lo que me han dicho es que se dio
cuenta de que bueno estas cosas él no
sabía cómo pero estas cosas son las que
se transmiten de un padre a su
descendencia y empezó a describir cómo
eran transmitidas observo que incluso si
se tienen dos de estos tienden a
segregar sé cuándo se va a la siguiente
generación
y qué es lo que entendemos por
segregación o supongo que podemos decir
la ley de la segregación
se cree gasión
bueno eso significa que si esta es una
planta de chícharos y estas son las
versiones que tengo a mi descendencia le
podría transmitir una a mayúscula la
alta o le podría transmitir la minúscula
le podría transmitir la versión roja del
factor de color de la flor o le podría
transmitir la versión rosa y también se
dio cuenta de que si le transmito la a
mayúscula o la a minúscula es
independiente de si le transmito la b
mayúscula o la b minúscula por lo tanto
se asocian de manera independiente como
éste se ordena o asocia es independiente
de cómo éste se ordena o asocia y así
tenemos la ley de la asociación
independiente
de la asociación
y de un diente
y también observó que algunas de estas
versiones dominan sobre la otra por lo
que si un descendiente tiene una versión
alta y una baja la versión alta es
dominante el rasgo observado será el
alto y la única manera en que se va a
poder observar el rasgo bajo es si tiene
dos versiones bajas y así esto lo
describió como la ley de la uniformidad
lee
la
un y por mi lado
y si todo esto es completamente nuevo
para ti te invito a ver los vídeos de
genética mendeliana en kant academy ya
que esta es sólo una pequeña apreciación
histórica pero incluso con lo
trascendental que fue el trabajo de
méndez también es importante darse
cuenta de lo que él no sabía él no tenía
ni idea de cómo esto sucedía a nivel
molecular oa nivel celular y fue hasta
la década de 1900 que comenzaron a
aparecer teorías bastante robustas
acerca de cómo esto suceden
y así en 1902 y 1903 1902
en 1903 a estos dos caballeros de manera
independiente se les ocurrió la teoría
cromosómica de la herencia también
conocida como la teoría cromosómica de
sharon y burberry ya que más o menos al
mismo tiempo ambos comenzaron a darse
cuenta de que a lo mejor los cromosomas
eran el mecanismo molecular o el
mecanismo celular por el cual estos
factores se segregan y asocian
independientemente déjame escribir eso
esta es la teoría cromosómica
teoría
cromosómica
sarán
del débil
y aun cuando están empezando a decir que
tal vez los cromosomas tienen algo que
ver con esto ellos todavía no sabían
exactamente que hay dentro de un
cromosoma que está permitiendo de alguna
manera que esta información sea
codificada y vamos a llegar a eso en un
momento más y cuál fue su idea clave
bueno empezaron a mirar en el interior
de las células y por cierto la meiosis
se observó después de que méndez
publicara sus leyes de la herencia y
luego como los cromosomas se comportan
durante la meiosis fue descubierto
después de eso entonces volver y sharan
estuvieron de forma independiente
diferentes organismos
walter se harán estudios saltamontes y
theatre volver y estudiado erizos de mar
y observaron la meiosis la reproducción
y la fertilización y vieron que los
cromosomas hacían cosas que eran muy
similares a la ley de la segregación
la ley de la asociación independiente y
la ley de la uniformidad y hablaremos
más acerca de la ley de la uniformidad
en vídeos futuros y lo que observaron
fue lo siguiente digamos que se tiene un
organismo aquí y este organismo
particular tiene dos pares de cromosomas
homólogos esto solo lo hice para
simplificar esto un poco y que significa
cromosomas homólogos pues bien estos dos
son cromosomas diferentes pero parecen
ser muy similares parece como si
tuvieran la misma longitud el mismo
tamaño y la misma forma por lo que este
es un par de cromosomas homólogos y este
es otro par de cromosomas homólogos así
que si los cromosomas homólogos son dos
cromosomas que se ven muy similares pero
tal vez son un poco diferentes no
estamos seguros entonces tal vez esto se
ajusta a lo que está pasando por aquí
con estos factores y tal vez uno de
estos cromosomas de alguna manera
contiene lo que codifica para la
mayúscula
y tal vez el otro cromosoma en una parte
similar del mismo contiene lo que
codifica para la minúscula ahora esto
está empezando a cobrar sentido porque
los cromosomas homólogos que son
similares entre sí parece que codifican
para los mismos factores para los mismos
genes pero puede haber alguna variación
entre estos cromosomas y sharon y volver
y no fueron capaces de secuenciar los
cromosomas por lo tanto ellos no sabían
ellos ni siquiera sabían que el adn era
lo importante en los cromosomas pero
ellos dijeron bueno parece que estas dos
cosas si nos fijamos en el proceso de la
meiosis parece que se segregan unos de
otros por ejemplo este cromosoma que
correspondería a la letra a mayúscula se
replica así que esta es la letra a
mayúscula y luego esta es la minúscula
justo aquí es posible que ocurra un
entrecruzamiento cromosómico y hablamos
de eso cuando vimos la meiosis
revisar ese vídeo si este concepto te
parece poco familiar pero luego se
segregan aquí están las mayúsculas
y luego estas cromáticas hermanas se
separan así que esta es a mayúscula y a
mayúscula
y por acá están las minúsculas
estás a minúsculas se segregan y se
asocian independientemente de los otros
cromosomas por lo tanto está por aquí
podría ser la d mayúscula
y esta podría ser la de minúscula
e independientemente de si aquí hay una
b mayúscula o una minúscula puede haber
una a mayúscula o una a minúscula por lo
tanto parece que estos cromosomas se
asocian independientemente y así se les
ocurrió esta teoría cromosómica ya que
parece que tal vez los cromosomas son lo
que contienen a estos factores
hereditarios de los que mendel estaba
hablando porque parece que los
cromosomas se comportan de manera muy
similar a los factores hereditarios tal
vez los cromosomas codifican para varios
de estos factores hereditarios que se
segregan y se asocian de manera
independiente y como sabemos ahora
tenían razón por lo tanto esto es muy
muy importante pero también es
importante darse cuenta de que no
estaban seguros establecieron una teoría
pudieron hacer algunas observaciones con
los saltamontes y los erizos de mar
y vieron los patrones entre lo que
méndez le estaba describiendo y la
manera en que los cromosomas se
comportan durante la meiosis y entonces
sabían que cada uno de estos productos
de la meiosis
cada uno de estos gametos formarían
junto con otros gametos los siguientes
organismos y decían oh mira los padres
pueden contribuir ya sea con la a
mayúscula o con la a minúscula
o bien con la b mayúscula o con la b
minúscula por lo tanto esto es muy
similar a lo que méndez le estaba
describiendo por lo que ellos sentaron
las bases para la teoría pero todavía no
estaban seguros ellos no lo prueban
definitivamente y tomara otra década más
o menos antes de que sea aprobada
definitivamente y aún entonces nadie
estaba realmente seguro de exactamente
como son codificados estos diferentes
rasgos y para ello hubo que esperar un
poco más